we'll play tell me what you think Mike
will made-it and I'll produce music my
style is translating different and turn
out the box when all my homies were like
freestyle i will be in the lunchroom
I'll be the one beating on the table and
then my dad bought me my first big
machine and i really like just started
teaching myself i was always like a fan
of music but i never knew that i would
like it do music I think the baseline I
need to be moving slower I had a whole
bunch of songs out like on the mixtape
circuits and it was just all free music
because that's like how the new
generation is like a lot of people will
responding to a lot of different songs
or whatever that I have out but nobody
knew that I produce any other tracks tom
was my man I need my own tag and then
ever since then I just put it on all my
beats and then everybody just hired the
tagging was just like yo that's dope
I saw that wondering like you know I
have like so many songs out here but I'm
not getting any money I started
realizing I ok I have to get my business
together I can't just be super creative
so I teamed up with my manager and then
up to that it was just like you know
everything just took off the best way to
make money in this industry is if you're
creative you don't really need to speak
for yourself on the business side you
like the business people speak business
and then you just stay creative but at
the same time you have to stay on top of
your business and no one's going on at
all times and you just have to know your
worth I got like creative tricks what
we're taught knows I just blurted out
ideas I can't really call like when I'm
the most creative sometimes it's late at
night sometimes it's early in the
morning I used I was set up in my
bedroom I just rolled out of bed and
just get up and just start making beats
and then just go back to sleep I hit is
just something that moves people I'm the
cold I locked in my head but I really
don't know how to explain it whatever
the future brings I'm pretty much ready
for put on for like I just made it yet
like I feel like I'm 25 and start
grinding